messieurs bonsoir toute la scandinavie
il appelle aujourd'hui le pirate tout
cela parce qu'en suédois pierrât est un
nom bien compliqué à prononcer mais cela
n'empêche pas l'europe du nord
d'applaudir à demain la très belle
course de ce français de 25 ans qui hier
pas très loin de stockholm a gagné la
plus belle course de ski de fond qui
soit la course du roi la vasaloppet 85
km en un peu plus de cinq heures
si nous revenons aujourd'hui encore sur
cette victoire ne pas simplement par
chauvinisme nous le sommes bien un peu
c'est vrai mais c'est aussi parce
qu'elle est révélatrice du développement
d'un sport en plein essor en france et
qui va grâce à ce jeune vosgien franchir
un nouveau palier ignorer vilipendé même
le ski de fond c'était le parent pauvre
du ski alpin autant dekhili périllat
goitschel l'âge d'or du ski on en
parlait rarement
la vapeur semble renversé aujourd'hui
l'élite du ski alpin ce chef et le ski
de fond prend la tête
au chapitre de la popularité la france
en compétition se dote des moyens pour
réussir
allant même jusqu'à s'attacher les
services d'un entraîneur venu du grand
nord partout on apprend à connaître et
aimer ce sport liés à la vie secrète de
la nature c'est la revanche de la
moyenne sur la haute montagne
le plus bel exemple
vous l'avez découvert hier la victoire
de jean-paul pierre adam la vasaloppet
la plus belle course de ski de fond du
monde c'est à la fois inespéré fabuleux
et prouve que les sacrifices qu'exige la
haute compétition ne sont pas vains
l'exemple de piera doit en effet servir
à la base car désormais rien ne sera
plus comme avant dans le ski de fond
français une nouvelle raison d'espérer
et oui le ski de fond un sport
terriblement populaire en scandinavie
regardez des à moi c'est quelque 12000
concurrents qui se sont lancés sur les
traces de jean paul pira sport presque
inconnu en france il ya dix ans mais qui
depuis quelques années se développe de
façon assez spectaculaire
trois cent mille trois cents en 1960
les adeptes du ski de fond cent cinq
cent mille aujourd'hui une croissance
spectaculaire comparable à celle du
cyclotourisme ou de la course est
d'ailleurs ces disciplines
on en ferait l'un des points comme la
nature l'espace l'effort librement doser
le silence la possibilité de contact
humain
il était donc logique que le ski de fond
devienne un sport populaire qui n'a pas
fini de faire des années les agences de
voyages comme les organismes de vacances
ont bien senti que c'était un besoin et
nous jouons la carte du ski de fond en
collaboration avec les communes
d'accueil c'est à dire que partout où
les communes d'accueil sont disposés à
créer des foyers de ski de fond
communaux et a collaboré à ce
développement et bien nous sommes prêts
à ouvrir toutes nos installations
c'est ce qui s'est passé en haute loire
c'est ce qui se passe en lozère c'est ce
qui se passe également dans les vosges
donc chirurgicale menée dans le jura
l'eulex nous avons village qui est
essentiellement spécialisée dans le ski
de fond le ski de fond possède une
clientèle potentielle d'environ 12
millions de personnes et de gros atouts
pour les séduit la faible proportion des
risques d'accident le choix des
variantes qu'il offre la promenade et la
haute compétition
sans oublier la randonnée et puis aussi
le coût de revient relativement bas de
l'équipement
en démarrant d'aller plus bas prix
disons 250 fois un quart de ce type 46
francs la paire de bâtons que les et une
fixation 43 francs et chaussures 125
francs ensuite le pantalon si on veut on
peut mettre un jean ou pantalon lui mais
vos 215 points un coup de vent qui peut
croire il ya dix ans 69 ans
et voilà vous avez un ensemble correct
on étale ses cinq actifs
alors pour faire une comparaison entre
le ski alpin et ski de fond vous
analysez pris entre des skis et un
équipement très moyen enfin ce qui suit
si une fixation de sécurité une paire de
chaussures très moyenne une perte
battant l'anorak voyant aussi est en
pente à course ainsi que la paire de
gants il faut compter un autre époque
1710 francs
d'ailleurs plus du double que le ski
fond de 2000 paires de ski de fond vendu
dans les années 60 on est passé à 100
mille aujourd'hui l'évolution est en
cours
elle n'est pas terminée et déjà
certaines stations pense créer des
circuits de ce qu'ils font ap ap
argument les secours alpins paye
l'entretien des pistes au travers des
remontées mécaniques alors le ski de
fond et le ski chômage us qui de la
liberté je pense qu'il faut que cette
pratique demeure gratuite
il est en effet impensable de faire
payer des skieurs de fond qui ne demande
rien à la collectivité publique
par contre si ses skieurs veulent un
certain nombre de services les pistes
damées des pistes balisées une
organisation de la sécurité il est
absolument normal que ces services
soient
soit rémunéré à la collectivité
d'accueil en général ces collectivités
locales sont de petites communes de
moyenne montagne qui ne disposent pas de
ressources budgétaires très très grande
il est donc nécessaire que le skieur de
fond contribuer par une redevance à le
au financement de ces infrastructures
en attendant la rançon du succès les
organisateurs de la traversée du vercors
petit vasaloppet française refuse du
monde
ces derniers passent hier de crise que
s'est ouvert il ya un peu plus de trois
heures le conseil des ministres de
l'agriculture des neuf à bruxelles crise
ouverte bien sûr par la position
française qui refusent d'appliquer le
nouveau taux de 23 % fixé par la
commission européenne pour les mentons
compensatoires agricole français une
augmentation préjudiciable aux
agriculteurs français
surtout en cette période d'incertitude
politique où le franc c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire manque un petit peu de
tonus bruxelles
maurice werther techniquement compliqué
est au fond très simple en refusant
d'augmenter cette espèce d'impôt
agricole que sont les montants
compensatoires
la france est juridiquement mises en
infraction ça c'est indiscutable mais le
dossier de fond c'est à dire le dossier
économique il dossier politique ce n'est
pas la même chose
ainsi les montants compensatoires à
l'origine palliatifs provisoires
endurant sont devenus différents ils ont
changé de nature et risque de dénaturer
la politique agricole commune
si les ministres de l'agriculture des
pays du marché commun sont sensibles
dans la situation politique particulière
et délicate actuelle aux argumentations
française il n'est pas impossible de
trouver parmi le foisonnement de la
législation communautaire d'un moyen
d'arriver à une conciliation et à une
solution acceptable
en fin d'après-midi le bruit courait
même que l'atmosphère n'était pas
mauvaise et la conciliation pas
impossible
ce sera un dossier difficile
techniquement et juridiquement mais
c'est un dossier qui est étudiée depuis
un an il n'aurait pas pris cette
dimension politique et cette dimension
de distorsion de concurrence
si les différents partenaires et si la
commission avait solutionner le problème
demandée par plusieurs états dont la
france
l'abattement sur les montants
compensatoires mais c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons un bon dossier et
nous espérons et demandons que des
solutions soient prises avant demain
soir pour protéger les agriculteurs
jusqu'à la perte de la prochaine période
de fixation des prix qui aura lieu début
avril est bien évident que cette crise
de l'agriculture européenne n'est pas
sans incidence sur le débat politique
français un débat qui a six jours
maintenant du premier tour ne s'est
guère élargi pendant le week end
à noter quand même un nouveau point de
polémique à gauche dans une interview à
notre confrère le matin robert fabre dit
que ses amis des radicaux de gauche
n'ont n'accepterons pas de nouvelles
nationalisations et qu'ils sont déjà
allés aux limites de leurs concessions
la réponse de georges marchais qui
ouvrira la série des petites phrases
sélectionnés par sotirio est assez
sévère au micro de rtl ce matin georges
marchais si robert fabre était honnête
ce qui devrait dire ce n'est pas je ne
veux plus de nouvelles nationalisations
mais je ne veux plus des
nationalisations qui ont été décidées
dans le programme commun de 72
c'est de la malhonnêteté politique
georges séguy pour la cgt estime que
monsieur fabre fait peu de cas des
prérogatives des organisations
syndicales et de leurs compétences
pierre mendès france répond aux
questions des journalistes du nouvel
observateur et déclare notamment
il faut choisir entre le respect du
suffrage universel et une crise de
régime au cours d'un débat au micro de
radio monte carlo au christian bonnet
ministre de l'intérieur membre du parti
républicain déclaré
messieurs mitterrand mendès france et
rocker veulent remettre en cause les
institutions et cela un président de la
république ayant la personnalité d'une
autre élu au suffrage universel garant
des institutions n'acceptera jamais
d'être un président ou rabais réplique
de paul laurent membre du bureau
politique du parti communiste en cas de
victoire de la gauche il n'y a que deux
solutions possibles pour monsieur
giscard d'estaing soit se soumettre soit
se démettre mais dans la mesure où le
président de la république annonce qu'il
laissera faire la politique du programme
commun nous ne voulons pas plus
enfin jean marie le pen président du
front national appelle les français à ne
voter ni pour l'utopie de la gauche ni
pour la décadence de la majorité
deuxième traditions de nos journaux
depuis quelques jours les grands leaders
en campagne vous avez pu voir
successivement les portraits de raymond
barre jacques chirac et georges marchais
hier soir il nous manque encore l'un de
ceux que michel jobert a appelé un petit
peu malicieusement la bande des quatre
je peux parler de françois mitterrand
françois mitterrand vu par le hit de
daniel grandclément et par l'objectif de
jean françois renaud jean françois rey
nous assisté de pascal piot
nous regardons ce sujet sur françois
mitterrand françois mitterrand c'est se
ménager des espaces de repos et de
réflexion
ce jour là il avait passé la matinée
chez son frère en charente à quelques
dizaines de kilomètres de là
près de 2000 personnes avaient
interrompu leur journée de travail pour
entendre le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste c'est la candidate qu'il
venait soutenir
il sera relativement bref une heure de
discours
la journée ne fait que commencer tous
les moyens de locomotion sont utilisés
pour cette campagne
mais c'est bien sur l'avion à learjet de
location que l'on choisit quand c'est
possible
l'ambiance est celle d'un grand mythe il
retrouve la chaleur de la campagne
présidentielle contrairement aux
réunions des autres dirigeants
socialistes
l'union de la gauche sans aussi vivace
qu'avant le mois de septembre
le discours est unitaire on applaudit à
la critique de la majorité actuelle suez
c'est surtout de l'appel au désistement
dont se souviendront les spectateurs
et
la salle se vide et le football dispute
à l'histoire du socialisme dans les
conversations des derniers nantais qui
rentrent chez eux
déjeuner à charleville dans la grande
salle de la mairie une très vieille
municipalité socialiste
opération carte postale chacun y va de
sa question
elles sont diverses qu'est ce que
françois mitterrand pense de
l'athlétisme nucléaire de l'enseignement
privé du sport de compétition
georges séguy de valéry giscard
d'estaing du programme de la cfdt du
marché comme de l'équipe de football en
argentine pour la coupe du monde de
l'automobile
c'est enfin du travail au noir entendu
avions encore le temps de répondre aux
questions d'un journaliste embarqué avec
nous pour nous socialistes c'est sain
nous en appellerons au soutien de la
gauche toute entière de la gauche unie
du rassemblement de la gauche du courant
populaire derrière le candidat unique de
la gauche par circonscription et
quelques candidats celui que le
chiffrage universelle aura placé le 12
le mieux placé pour l'emporter
paris en fin ou la promenade devient
vite bousculèrent avec georges sarre
dans le 11e arrondissement le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste goûtent
aux joies et aux inconvénients du bain
de foule
voilà pour cette campagne françois
mitterrand aura participé à 156 meetings
réunions ou conférence de presse demain
dernier de portraits des quatre
mousquetaires qui en sont cinq en
réalité jean pierre soisson du 12 mars
et sa grande soeur du 19 nous avons
commencé à vous les présenter tout au
long de la semaine nous rentrerons
davantage dans le détail mais sachez
d'ores et déjà que vous pourrez les
suivre devant votre téléviseur à l'aide
d'une carte qui va vous rendre beaucoup
de services une carte des
circonscriptions de france édité par
l'hygiène l'institut géographique
national
mais d'abord qu'est ce que l'hygiène
pour les spécialistes de l'hygiène
l'institut géographique national
la carte de france c'est d'abord trois
millions de photographies la prise de
vue aérienne a remplacé le relevé
topographique de jadis
elle est le fondement de la cartographie
moderne et comme le travail de
l'institut géographique national sert de
base à toutes les cartes vendues en
france est bien c'est de cet avion
peut-être qu'à et et tracer l'itinéraire
routier de vos vacances
douze appareils basés à creil et 36
navigant hautement qualifiés c'est
l'escadrille de l'hygiène à laquelle
font appel d'ailleurs de nombreux pays
étrangers
à charge aux volailles de 20
ok
un plan de vol précis des passages
successifs le terrain est photographiée
par bandes parallèles qui se chevauchent
en partie on pourra les assemblées avec
exactitude la caméra est télécommandé
par le navigateur qui a son viseur dans
le poste de pilotage
il faut reconstituer sur le papier tout
l'information recueillie cela met en
oeuvre une technique complexe et des
appareils de haute précision
le tracé est en même temps mise en
mémoire sur un ordinateur
le matériau de base est désormais à la
disposition des cartes grâce qui
ajouteront les couleurs les noms de
lieux et les détails que l' enquête sur
le terrain seul peut révéler de la prise
de vue à la vente des cartes au public
cela représente deux ans de travail et
comme les hommes façonnent le sol en
fonction de leurs besoins comme les
villes s'agrandissent que les campagnes
se transforme il faut recommencer sans
cesse pour se tenir à jour
cela exige des moyens considérables et
l'amélioration constante des techniques
pas ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'elles ont probablement beaucoup plus
évolué au cours des vingt dernières
années qu'au cours de tout le siècle
précédent
la carte n'est qu'un des moyens on peut
même imaginer que c'est un moyen qui
peut demain disparaître en tout cas dès
aujourd'hui l'information est stockée
tantôt sur des pellicules sensible
tantôt sur des bandes magnétiques ou des
disques
ce système électronique permet de
traiter des observations reçues de
quatre types différents de satellites
artificiels utilisés par l'igpn
mais il peut aussi se comporter comme
une machine à dessiner
voici la carte des départements français
et bien cette à partir de données
précises ainsi traités que l'hygiène à
dessiner la carte des circonscriptions
électorales publiées en encart dans
l'hebdomadaire le point aujourd'hui une
carte qui vous permettra de noter les
résultats des législatives
les 12 et 19 mars en suivant l'émission
spéciale d'antenne 2 et europe 1 réalisé
en direct de la grande galerie de
l'hôtel de lassay résidence du président
de l'assemblée nationale
tout dans cette campagne a été dit ou
presque mais au travers des arguments
qui vole trop trop bas c'est selon il
manque souvent la réponse à une question
de base à quoi va servir le bulletin de
vote des 12 et 19 et plus simplement à
quoi sert un député
l'explication qui va suivre pourra
peut-être paraître un petit peu simple à
ceux qui connaissent bien les rouages de
la politique mais croyez moi elle n'est
pas inutile pour se remettre en mémoire
certain nombre de vérités l'assemblée
nationale issue du suffrage universel
est la représentation de la nasse tôt
l'assemblée nationale siège depuis 1795
au palais bourbon
elle comprend quatre cent quatre-vingt
dix députés élus pour cinq ans qui se
réunissent dans deux sessions ordinaires
d'environ trois mois chacune
elle comprend un bureau placé sous
l'autorité d'un président élu dont la
fonction en fait un des premiers
personnages de l'état le président est
assisté de six vice-présidents première
mission de l'assemblée nationale votée
la loi le gouvernement dépose des
projets de doigts et les députés des
propositions de lois qui sont examinées
les unes les autres par l'une des six
commissions concernées affaires
culturelles et sociales affaires
étrangères défense nationale finance loi
constitutionnelle production échanges
le texte est ensuite de discuter en
séance publique article par article est
fréquemment soumis à des modifications
appelé amendement pour être adopté
définitivement le texte en discussion
doit être voté dans les mêmes termes par
le sénat ce qui n'est pas toujours très
simple les allers retours entre les deux
assemblées porte d'ailleurs le nom image
et de navettes
selon l'importance des textes le vote
s'effectue soit à malves et soit à
l'aide d'un clavier électronique disposé
devant chaque tenue des tic aux portes
trois touches paie pour ses contres à
abstentions l'assemblée nationale a
également pour fonction d'examiner de
discuter et de voter le budget de la
france
autre mission des députés contrôler
l'action du gouvernement
pour cela ils posent des questions il y
a les questions écrites environ 20000
par législature
elle appelle des réponses à des sujets
particuliers il y a les questions orales
elles sont posées en séance publique
de même que les questions dites
d'actualité qui appelle une réponse
immédiate pour certains sujets le
parlement peut constituer les
commissions d'information des commission
denquête ou des commissions de contrôle
notamment en ce qui concerne la gestion
de l'état la politique générale du
gouvernement est exposé devant
l'assemblée nationale par le premier
ministre dont l'action peut être remise
en cause par ce que l'on appelle une
motion de censure pour être adopté cette
motion de censure doit recueillir la
majorité des voix
le premier ministre ainsi contesté remet
sa démission au président de la
république qui désigne un nouveau
premier ministre
intégralement publié dans le journal
officiel tous les débats sont ainsi
portés à la connaissance des citoyens
qui peuvent s'ils le désirent se faire
une opinion personnelle en assistant aux
séances de l'assemblée nationale
dernière formation française pour la
journée le cnpf accepté aujourd'hui de
revoir la demande d'andré bergeron
l'accord de juin dernier sur les pré
retraites c'est cela afin de permettre
aux travailleurs qui étaient partis en
retraite avant cet accord de pouvoir
bénéficier de 80 % de leur salaire net
la politique étrangère donc mort
aujourd'hui à rabat de kaïd ahmed qaïda
remède plus connu sous le pseudonyme de
commandant slimane secrétaire général du
fln et l'un des négociateurs d'evian il
était passé à l'opposition à houari
boumédiène il ya environ six ans
l'italie maintenant avec cette situation
qui de france peut tout de même par être
assez étonnante pour la première fois
depuis 30 ans les communistes vont
entrer dans la majorité parlementaire
ça veut dire tout simplement qu'ils
mèneront leurs voix à celles des
démocrates chrétiens
ce qui est évidemment assez surprenant
vite marais et cela va permettre au
président de la république italienne de
pouvoir former dès cette semaine un
nouveau gouvernement président est sans
doute par l'inévitable
démocrate-chrétien yoyo andreotti et
pour nos confrères italiens
c'est en tout cas un succès pour le pci
car depuis trente ans il suivait il
essayer d'arriver à ce jour et ce jour
est arrivé
maintenant je disais tout à l'heure ils
sont officiellement associé à la
majorité donc
je crois que quelque chose a changé en
italie est ce que dans leur guerre va se
contenter de ce strapontin
je ne vois pas je ne crois pas car dans
le type des communistes arriver à cela
il s'arrêter a certainement là où ils
sont vraiment où seuls à la porte du
pouvoir je ne crois pas que berlin guen
et surtout les communistes le parti la
base du parti pas se contenter de ce
résultat qui est positif mais qui n'est
pas le gouvernement
voilà dix ans pour schématiser que
l'italie va se retrouver demain avec un
gouvernement démocrate chrétien comme
avant mais avec une majorité
parlementaire disons de salut public
comprenant cinq ou six parties dont les
communistes une majorité parlementaire
d'urgence parce qu il y avoue en douter
en italie des problèmes très urgent à
régler et je n'en prend qu'un exemple un
chiffre le déficit budgétaire de l'état
pour l'an dernier ses montées c'est
presque intraduisible en français
à vingt-quatre mille milliards de lires
communiste et démocrates chrétiens vont
donc se mettre au travail ensemble pour
tenter de redonner à l'économie
italienne
un semblant d'ordre le plan d'austérité
est déjà pratiquement adopté on y trouve
bien entendu
l'augmentation du prix de l'essence
pourtant déjà à près de 3 francs le
litre augmentation de tous les services
publics téléphone transport etc et
diminution des dépenses de chaque
ministère ce qui déjà fait grincer des
dents chez les communistes ceux de la
base qui trouve que la note à payer pour
le strapontin offert à leur leader
berlinger sera au coût trop élevé il ya
une heure nous apprenions que le prénom
carter faisaient appel à la loi tu as tu
parlais une loi d'urgence destinée à
imposer une dent prix du travail dans
les mines de charbon des appalaches
paralysée depuis trois mois par une dame
des mineurs et syndicats avaient accepté
de stopper le mouvement
mais la base ne les avait pas suivis
alors tout de suite à washington au
téléphone jacques séguin alouettes à
parler comme tout pouvoir au président
des états unis japon que donner leur
encontre et vie de reprendre le travail
pour une période de 90 jours elle a déjà
été appliquée 34 fois en 40 ans et sans
grand succès à chacune de ces occasions
aujourd'hui qu'à faire appel
appel urgent aux accents dramatiques les
mineurs reprennent immédiatement le
travail at il dit tain c'est la sécurité
du pays est en jeu dans certains états
comme l'ohio et la pennsylvanie
les réserves de charbon sont
pratiquement épuisés et cette grève qui
en est à son troisième mois précise avec
un hiver très rude aux états unis ces
mineurs réclament un remboursement total
de leurs frais médicaux
les patrons ne sont pas d'accord c'est
carter c'est la crise va encore
affaiblir un peu plus sa position par la
crise du charbon a ralenti l'activité
économique du pays et fait augmenter le
nombre des chômeurs
voilà je crois que c'est le moment ou
jamais alain dumait de faire un petit
peu le point sur la santé du dollar il
semble que la monnaie américain est
touché le fond et que désormais elle se
redresse maintenant en tout cas
aujourd'hui le dollar a regagné 7
centimes par rapport au franc français
ce qui fait une hausse de 1 5%
disons que si mouvement se continue
jusqu'à la fin de la semaine le dollar
vaudrait à la fin de la semaine 5 francs
alors ce qu'on peut dire à propos de la
situation et dollars soit environ 2
sortes de choses d'abord le dollar peut
difficilement tomber plus bas
parce que d'abord la baisse de leurs
n'arrange personne ni le japon ni
l'europe et encore moins les états unis
deuxièmement à 4 françois 30-15 delcourt
qu'on faisait encore vendredi
disons que dollars brûle les doigts de
ceux qui en détiennent et un tel prix un
prix de braderie les émirs du pétrole
qu'il est saine peut être 100 milliards
de dollars pourrait bien demander le
remboursement des avoirs en dollars ça
serait une catastrophe
ça serait un jeudi noir en passant
et puis ça c'est une journée noire pour
l'ensemble du monde industriel et puis
troisièmement sous-évalué le dollar
c'est sous-estimer aussi la capacité de
l'économie américaine à réagir à
s'adapter bref ares déploie son économie
si bien que pour toutes ces raisons je
crois que le dollar avait effectivement
touché le fond de la baisse et
maintenant il ya des réseaux pour que le
dollar remonte et paradoxalement parmi
ces raisons la grève des mineurs qui a
paralysé l'est des états unis 20 90
jours qui va mettre au chômage en tout
cas en sous-emploi plus d'un million de
travailleurs aux états unis mais ce
mouvement risque de faire prendre
conscience à l'opinion publique la
nécessité qu'il ya aujourd'hui à
économiser l'énergie
si l'opinion publique américaine prend
conscience de ça
carter fort d'être passé tout ou partie
de son plan énergétique
le déficit commercial américain peut se
stabiliser et le dollar remontait à mars
ce sera tout pour l'étranger deux autres
cadavres découverts ce matin dans les
décombres des immeubles du 16e
arrondissement ravagée il ya trois
semaines par une explosion de gaz celui
d'un jeune garçon et de sa mère
gardienne dans cet immeuble un bilan qui
s'établit maintenant à dix morts et deux
disparus
mémé guérini le dernier caïds du milieu
marseillais libéré conditionnellement
guérini qui a 70 ans bénéficie en fait
une grâce médicale
il est en effet très malade nous
refermons ce journal comme nous l'avons
ouvert c'est-à-dire par du sport avec
l'arrivée de la première étape
paris-nice à auxerre et commis hier un
prologue celle hollandais knetemann
qu'il a importé la météo de demain
maintenant et bien deux semaines du
printemps il fera encore bourreau sur
presque tout le pays je dis presque
parce qu'il y aura quelques nuages et
quelques ondées sur la corse et dans le
nord-est
températures en hausse et cela c'est
aussi une bonne chose
à 23h40 vous retrouverez patrick lecocq
je vous souhaite quant à moi ont donc
tous mes confrères une très très bonne
soirée